J'aime tes tatouages ​​quels sont ces
chiffres sur ton bras oh c'est la date à laquelle
mon père est mort il était pompier il est mort dans un
incendie il y a 17 ans oh mon dieu je suis tellement désolé
ça va pas
qui est là Scott plus chéri il a 24 ans
ans quoi qu'il soit il est maintenant tu
dois t'en aller
désolé maman tu sais que ta fille est
devenue plus intelligente il est allé à l'université et
nous a abandonnés
mais je suis toujours là je serai là pour l'
Afrique ouais je veux devenir un vrai
tatoueur  artiste ton travail est fou et
cohérent Obama c'est vrai j'adore ton
tatouage c'est mon préféré je
sors avec quelqu'un depuis un petit moment maintenant
le premier gars avec qui tu sors en 17 ans est un
pompier juste comme ça tu ne penses pas
que c'est bizarre
tu vas devoir tirer un
peu plus ton poids ici peut-être aider à casser
ses enfants à l'école Kelly le connais-tu
c'est un nouvel ami tu ok tu sais que
tu pourrais me dire d'accord eh bien je l'ai
entraînée dans la voiture elle ne va pas  pause tu as
déjà pensé à mettre la veste
pourquoi me demanderais-tu même t  chapeau c'est amusant d'
être pompier c'est bien
si vous n'avez pas d'enfants pour ne pas les
écraser quand vous ne rentrez pas à la maison qu'une
fois vous faites que tout le monde autour de vous se sente
fou les gens ont l'air normaux puis ils
traînent avec vous  et puis ils sont Jack
Nicholson dans le brillant ma mère tu essaies
de me noyer [ __ ] de piscine tu
fais environ huit pieds de haut je vais te dire quelque chose
papa était un héros et les héros sont nécessaires
et ils devraient être autorisés à avoir des
familles
toi  tu dois te ressaisir le temps
passe très vite pourquoi tu penses que
je fume de l'herbe tout le temps pour que je puisse le
ralentir il
y a comme si tout le monde était toujours
déçu de moi et je ne réponds jamais
aux attentes de personne hé merci d'avoir
écouté tout ça en un  des quelques
personnes qui me traitent tu sais comme une
personne tu es la bienvenue